John dingus foreign editor of National
Public Radio Late News reports from Matt
from Panama indicate that general
Noriega is just trying to decide who
he's going to give himself up to what's
going on behind the scenes down there
that you can tell us about well I wish I
knew I know some of the players because
of my travels I know the the Papal
Nuncio
Monsignor labora one of the most astute
diplomats in the whole diplomatic corps
in Panama somebody that and of course
the Vatican with a 2,000 year diplomatic
history I don't expect that the Vatican
is going to be buffaloed into some sort
of a quick decision for the sake of
political expediency on the other hand
it appears that so in other words what
you're hearing is outside the embassy
everybody is saying get rid of him throw
him out in the street put him on trial
the only question is giving them off
security so he doesn't get lynched on
his way to the courtroom inside the
Vatican embassy I suspect here there are
a lot of phone calls going back and
forth to Rome about how do we preserve
the tradition of church sanctuary a very
important issue and you have to recall
that the Vatican Embassy in Panama was
also the place where all of the
opposition people ran to when they were
being persecuted by Noriega certainly
the turnabout is fair play to a certain
extent and Noriega z-- status there is
colored by what happened when he was in
ruling in power what was the role of the
church when Noriega was empowered he
tried to suppress the church at all I
don't believe you could say he
suppressed the church directly the
church accepted the extent that the
church participated in in the political
opposition and it must be said that the
number one the church is not
particularly powerful in Panama compared
to say chilly even Brazil some of the
larger South American countries Panama
is certainly a Catholic country but as
we've seen in the news reports it's also
a country where there are a lot of other
religious traditions there's voodoo
Santeria
a lot of the
a population has other cults other than
pure Catholicism so the church while
it's influential as it is in every
country is not is far from being a
dominant force it's not that the
archbishop talks and everybody
immediately clicks their heels and and
moves off in that direction so he's the
archbishop McGrath who by the way speaks
English as you and I do and I believe
was born in the United States although
he's a Panamanian citizen he spoke out
against Noriega in beginning in 1987 and
gradually increased his criticism but in
my opinion never was successful at
becoming a kind of mediator somebody who
could really grab the problem and move
it toward a solution so I think you find
that reflected now in the fact that the
that the church and the government the
new government are floundering a bit you
have contradictory statements from the
Attorney General and the president
another opinion from Archbishop McGrath
it's hard to to say well well what do
they want what is the clear line that
has been put forward here well there is
talk that the charges might be filed by
Panama against Noriega what would be the
significance if that happens well that I
think and I think all of us are moving
in that direction would be a kind of a
solution because it would mean that
Noriega would be would remain in Panama
he would be submitted to the judgment of
his own people rather than to the United
States of course the the problem is that
whether he would get a fair trial in
Panama as opposed to the United States
certainly he's he has that problem in in
both places that the publicity against
him has been has been so extreme that
would be difficult to imagine that
however the most serious crimes of this
leader certainly have been the human
rights crimes the I would be very
interested in seeing a trial against him
on the killing of a dissident Google
Spadafora
in 1985 the the man who probably put put
together the information on drug dealing
that led to Noriega is being revealed
and all over the world as a drug
trafficker this is this morning's
Washington Times and there's a headline
Noriega tipped off by a spy and in this
story it says that the US intelligence
agencies intercepted a phone call
several days prior to the prior to the
invasion tipping off general Noriega
what can you tell us about that well
there have been a lot of intercepts that
come out about Panama it's it's a
country that's wired for sound almost
everything that goes on there and and
wired by Noriega as well as by our
people we have a place called the where
they're they call it the forest of
antennas the the island of antennas
there because it's a listening post for
all of Latin America so practically
every phone call that occurs inside of
Panama can be picked up by our people
and of course it's always been suspected
that most of the phone calls that we
carry out inside of Panama are picked up
by Noriega Spiegel I think there
probably were reports I have talked to a
friend of mine who's a photographer who
told me about that he was requested to
do to do work for the US military
a pursuant to a US military action two
weeks before the invasion he was putting
together all of his photo files and
giving them pictures of the entrances to
buildings and lot of this two weeks
before the invasion this is a person
without even a security clearance I
think the fact that we were preparing an
invasion was probably the worst kept
secret in in all of Central America
there must have been lots of telephone
calls back and forth saying it's coming
it's coming get ready I was told by
another source of mine in Panama City
that the a couple days before the
invasion
Noriega is people the dignity battalions
and the regular troops were scurrying
around like like large mice with RPGs
and
and and and guns getting ready for the
invasion so I don't while I'm sure that
somebody and and several people probably
called up and said it's coming I don't
believe that
I don't really accept the story that it
was some kind of an intelligence leak by
someone inside the US government who and
the traitorous implications that that
kind of leak would have good morning
welcome to this portion of our program
we're spending the next 40 minutes or so
talking about the latest development
from Panama we invite your questions and
comments for our guest this morning he's
John dingus he's foreign editor National
Public Radio and he's also the author of
a book soon to be published about
general Noriega the book is titled our
man in Panama why is that the title
there's a bit of irony
he's our man at least we thought he was
our man it turned out that when we told
him to pack up his bags and go home he
said that's not the way it works I was
serving you when it was in my interest
and when it's my interest not to serve
you anymore I will do my own thing and
that's what he did at the time when he
we perhaps thought that he was serving
us most in the early 80s helping us with
our operations in Central America was
the very time that he was making the
most money on receiving bribes from the
Colombian drug cartel so there's a great
deal of there's always been a great deal
of ambiguity about Manuel Noriega z--
relations with the United States in news
stories about whether or not he's coming
to the United States to stand trial
there's always a paragraph someplace in
the story about senior administration
officials some are worried about what he
might reveal what secrets he knows in
doing your book what did you find out
what does he know does he know things
that would be embarrassing to this
government of do people really maybe not
want him to stand trial because of that
yeah I think that they're quite a thing
quite a few things that he could bring
out he's a man I always I compare him in
the book to a a black J Edgar Hoover
because the racial factor is important
in Manuel Noriega he's somebody who does
know
a lot he keeps files not only on his his
own people in Panama but he kept files
on his relations with with US officials
it is said that he would arrange parties
for US officials and then film them I'm
not I don't consider that to be
confirmed and I find that the the
sources on it who are people who said oh
I was invited to the parties but I
didn't go but I'm sure I knew what was
going on in those parties and those
people must be really embarrassed I
think those are rather self-serving
stories I think the most serious
security leaks that he could be able to
bring out involve US intercept
operations in in Latin America all of
these electronic surveillance operations
that we had he was very familiar with
what we were doing in Central America
out of the Canal Zone but most of this
and perhaps he has something to
contribute to the iran-contra affair
because most of the companies that
Oliver North and Poindexter and Alfred
hakim were operating for their secret
arms pipeline to the Contras were
Panamanian companies but I think that
the I would say that most of that has
probably come out already
probably Noriega doesn't have anything
that would be more embarrassing than the
things that have already come out in the
North trial and the congressional
testimony so it would be more detailed
but probably along the lines of the
things that we already know Santa Monica
California good morning yes insofar as a
Bush was largely the Reagan's deputy
although his vice president he was also
the deputy in charge of all the drug
operations that the government and the
DEA was conducting in latin america over
over eight years don't you don't you
think that and and we had a photographs
videotape Noriega jovially exchanging
toast together on a couch it doesn't
suggest to you that that there may be a
more personal story of betrayal somehow
between bush and Noriega that perhaps he
tried to blackmail Bush and Bush had to
somehow knock him out of the box because
to send 27,000 troops the largest
evasions is world war ii into a into a
sovereign country seems to me an extreme
reaction just to move remove a guy who
was merely accused of drug-dealing of
you have thanks California for your
question this morning
well that is several really important
issues and I'd like to get back to the
the question of whether this is an
appropriate response to the amount of
drug trafficking that Noriega was
involved in but to the first question
it's often been asked whether Manuel
Noriega and George Bush had a personal
relationship one that would have
compromised Bush and and perhaps have
given Noriega some kind of a leverage
with the administration my opinion is
that and I'm familiar with the the photo
that they call a refers to is 1983
meeting which by the way was the second
meeting that Manuel Noriega had had with
George Bush the first was in 1960 1976
when George Bush was director of the CIA
at that time they were talking about
terrorist attacks against American
targets in the Canal Zone the first time
terrorism had ever been used against our
people and were were acts that were
linked to to Manuel Noriega and so
George Bush's first contact with Noriega
was to confront him on these alleged
acts of terrorism and basically to say
if you want to get along with the United
States you better stop this the 1983
meeting supposedly was about drug
activity but my information and I've
talked to several people who were in
that meeting is that drugs came up in
terms of money laundering and that the
United States was interested in
negotiating a treaty with with Panama to
to control the to regulate the way banks
operate in Panama
in such a way that it would be more
difficult to launder money the
implication that somehow George Bush
made a deal with Noriega you help us
with the Contras and and I won't pay
attention to your drug trafficking I
think is unsubstantiated and I don't
believe it
although I know that that picture was
used in the 1988 campaign in that way we
can go on to the question of the
justification of the invasion let's take
another call from Sugarland Texas
go ahead Texas thank you I want to talk
to you about the accidental search of
the Nicaraguan Embassy in Panama
either I'm functionally illiterate or
right in front of the gate it said
Nicaraguan Embassy now if that's an
accident you know I really would like to
know what's done on purpose and isn't
Bush being a little risky in this
suppose something like this happens to
one of our embassies somewhere and we
can't react to it because we did the
same thing to the Nicaraguan so hang up
and hear your answer thank you well I
haven't been there during this period
and I haven't seen that sign I I would
be very surprised if that was accidental
if anything I'm the United States has
been keeping very close tabs on the
Nicaraguans and the Cubans at the time
of the invasion and in the days
following the idea that we didn't know
where the Ambassador left I find hard to
believe I think that and of course our
explanation our president's explanation
was that we made a mistake that this is
an error that we shouldn't have gone
into that but the Panama the Nicaraguan
should not have had all those weapons in
the in that embassy residence
I think that's somewhat disingenuous
every embassy in the world in every
residents of ambassador's residence has
protection of one sort or another
particularly in a country that is facing
the possibility of a military
intervention as in fact occurred but I
think everybody recognizes that was a
violation of diplomatic immunity it was
an act of arrogance and
part of our troops and I probably won
that several people have been
reprimanded for because this kind of
thing really made us look bad by made
the United States forces look bad by
kind of bullying our way into this man's
house and then throwing emptying out his
drawers as if we were cheap burglars and
then and then saying well you had these
guns and therefore somehow it's
justified if you're watching outside the
United States we also invite you to join
in our discussion Valley international
code for the United States followed by
202 737 six seven three four and our
next call is from Oslo Norway good
morning good morning @m Borkowski from
Oslo Norway first I would like to thank
you for an excellent program and then I
have a question to John jinja's who and
what was Noriega power base and what do
you think is to left of it in Panama
Thank You Norway yeah that's the kind of
question that hasn't been raised very
much the power base has been a
combination of military and civilian
forces in Panama that has ruled the
country since 1968 in Panama Panama many
of the current political leaders who are
in the new government are associated
with the civilian politicians were
displaced in the military overthrow in
1968 in fact President ándara
was a deputy to then president our new
foe arias who ruled for only 11 days and
was overthrown by Omar Torrijos the
general Torrijos proceeded to reform the
country in in many quite important ways
he introduced legislation that was
considered to be quite progressive even
though he was an authoritarian dictator
he was of the left-of-center variety and
and somebody who introduced a lot of
changes which improved a lot of lower
middle class and middle class people and
particularly people of color and this is
a country with
black and an mestizo population and so
that's the power base a lot of people
identified with the military changes
with the Torrijos government in my
opinion Noriega never successfully put
on the mantle of Torrijos and was never
personally popular although as his as
the country became more polarized over
the last several years certainly a lot
of people saw that oh well we better go
with Noriega or this whole system is
going to be displaced and I think there
was a certain amount of popularity or
personalism attached to Noriega himself
but I don't think it was ever very
strong and I think that even his
supporters who in other words who wanted
to continue the system set up by
tortilla Coast became very restive with
the fact that Noriega is staying in
power staying on staying on he refuses
to step down in time for us to maintain
ourselves in power as a system and in
fact has happened with the invasion the
political parties that supported him are
decimated the whole military system is
destroyed and so that power base
whatever is left of the civilians in it
have no place to go no leaders Cleveland
good morning I also would like to talk
about Noriega shelter in the Panamanian
in the papal nunzio's residence in
Panama because it also shines a another
spotlight on fact that Kate bolduan Theo
is an ambassador of a foreign state and
with all that means they are definitely
distinct and separate entity as the
papal States are and the Pope and I
remember in Janis teracle event in 1928
Al Smith the governor of New York was
defeated hello can you hear me yes ma'am
hello yesterday
hello yes we can hear you Al Smith the
governor New York states ran for
president against Herbert Hoover and he
was soundly defeated and he was defeated
on the campaign that he would take
orders from the Vatican now we have just
a short time left this morning Cleveland
we've got the gist of your call
John dingus well I think the the point
she's making is that the Vatican is a
player on the world scene it always has
been and at one point or another this
was quite controversial in this country
and my experience our experience of
course it was the John Kennedy election
in 1960 where the idea that the Pope
somehow was was going to have an excess
of political influence over our
president came up and and I'm sure that
perhaps on this show and many other talk
shows the idea that the Pope having or
not having any legions as has come up
the the influence of the Vatican has
always been at least in our the past
centuries has always been political and
diplomatic and and not military but
certainly they've had a lot of they've
had a lot of power as we can see in in
this influence they really can influence
event our guest this morning is John
dingus he's foreign editor of National
Public Radio he's been with NPR since
1985 prior to that he worked in the
foreign desk of the Washington Post
he served in Latin America as a new
stringer he's also author of a book on
Chile called assassination on Embassy
Row he has an MA from Stanford in Latin
American Studies he's originally from
Emmetsburg Iowa and as we mentioned
earlier his new book coming out soon
about general Noriega is called our man
in Panama as an author of a book about
events that are a-changin almost hour to
hour what two problems has that
presented to you and and in your book
and how are you approaching that going
about making sure your book is the most
up-to-date it can be well that's that's
been a problem but it's also been an
opportunity I actually had finished the
epilogue about a week before the
invasion
and had been it had been set up I had
received the edited copy back and I was
ready to send it back and put the book
to bed when the invasion happened
we basically added a week on to our
schedule and I rewrote the epilogue and
included the narrative about the
invasion and my analysis of it and today
in fact I'm going up to my publishers
with the final copy and we'll actually
be in the bookstores in the first week
of month so in the first week of March
so it's a turnaround time of only two
months so the events will still be fresh
as we're coming out so you don't want to
wait just one more date as to see what
happens one more time well this story of
Noriega is the story of the relations
over the last 10 years and even over the
last 20 years and that's the story that
is essentially in the book the
day-to-day of how the invasion came down
is I think another story that will come
out in a year and that's something
that's a whole new process but but my
book essentially is about Noriega and
his relations with the United States and
I think that story is now complete and
so it what has happened is has really
wrapped things up brought it to a kind
of tragic conclusion I think one that
perhaps many of us did not expect but
the one that has made this an even more
important story than when we all began
to research this book several years ago
great Gorge New Jersey good morning hi
Lou hello c-span and hello mr. Dinges if
possible a quick comment in question we
just had a program concerning crimes of
hate it's my contention that a war
against drugs is one of the biggest
crimes of hate of all times it's very
hard for pleasure hating white people to
exist in the actual presence of people
who are not pleasure hating white people
I think the war against drugs is an
attempt to make the world safe for
pleasure hating white people by getting
rid of anybody who is not a pleasure
hating white person
that's the comment the question is this
the drug laws have always been and will
always be prime of facially
unconstitutional the power structure
knows it's going to have to repeal is
all this taking off after the cartels
just to get them out of the way so that
we can take over the business thanks for
calling in Jersey a little off our topic
this morning well but drugs is the main
issue here if it had not been for
Noriega as the allegations of Noriega
drug trafficking general Noriega would
be considered a US ally somebody that we
praised highly for rebuilding the Panama
Defense Forces preparing it for taking
over defense of the canal and Panama
would still be the country that was the
great exception to the violence in
Central America all of that seems very
ironic today is it's the only country
that we have actually invaded in Central
America but without the drug issue
that's the way things would be and and
the question is was it justified was it
proportionate for this kind of response
against somebody who's drug involvement
was of the magnitude of general Noriega
compared to say the the cartel leaders
who have been ensconced in Colombia for
many years
Noriega indeed and I'm convinced to the
evidence dealt and didn't deal directly
himself but he took protection money to
the amount of probably five to ten
million dollars a lot of money but the
one of the drug dealers who was a source
of mine who was now testifying against
Noriega he made twenty million dollars
on the drug trafficking and he'll be out
of prison in six more years and the
cartels that are the main target in a
country that we have of course not
invaded are dealing to the the level of
two or three billion dollars a year so
you have to keep it in proportion
Noriega was a fairly small fish in the
overall Latin America
drug enterprise Raleigh North Carolina
good morning good morning uh one of the
things that seemed to be to be the most
interesting about this was the telephone
intercept concerning the warning to
Noriega of course there are a number of
people who know who made that call that
was intercepted at both ends and as has
been published that came from the State
Department now the identity of the
person that made that call should be the
most interesting story to come out of
the whole affair thanks for the call
Raleigh we touched on that earlier
perhaps you could go back quickly yeah
well I don't know who made the call and
as I said I think there there may have
been uh I don't know whether it's
established whether somebody in the
State Department made a call that one
could say was an unauthorized security
violation because certainly there were
calls certainly there was a lot of
evidence that the invasion was about to
happen and it wouldn't have been a great
secret to Noriega that that there was a
buildup of US troops and that something
was going to come within a very few days
on a Lulu good morning yes uh if if not
states can arrest Noriega for drug
charges that means a Muslim country can
arrest say the United States for
somebody in the United States for
shipping alcohol in the Middle East or
some poor Muslim country doesn't the law
against alcohol how can United States
charge somebody who's not a citizen
there's not pledged allegiance to the
United States and then carrying out his
activities on in the United States
thanks Lulu that's an interesting issue
I'm not an expert on international law
but I've been reading some material by a
legal scholar at Tufts named Alfred
Ruben who I would really like to sit
across the table with and discuss this
issue he makes the point that that the
effects doctrine in international law is
accepted by the United States but not
accepted in most of the rest of the
world of the effects doctrine
as he explains it
states that if the effects of you of
your actions in your own country are
felt in this country and they are
criminal effects that we can go after
you in your own country bring you to
trial in this in this country and as the
caller points out and this of course is
part of what is going on in are going
after mud well Noriega there were I
don't believe it's alleged and I've
studied the indictments pretty carefully
that there are any of the actions that
Noriega himself carried out that
happened inside the territory boundaries
in the United States so we're talking
about the him being involved in a
conspiracy the effects of which were
felt in the drug trafficking in the
United States if you were to apply that
to other countries and to their
allegations against US officials I'm
sure we would see things in a very
different light I hadn't thought of the
idea of shipping alcohol into Muslim
countries but of course that is seen in
those countries is every bit as serious
as shipping cocaine into this country
but I think in looking at the world in
superpower politics there's a double
standard always operating when when the
World Court judges the United States we
tend to say well that's all very well
and good but we won't accept your
jurisdiction on that and when we but we
will hold smaller countries to a very
strict standard on these things and I
the reality the reality of the world is
that the stronger power gets their way
and international law is at best and an
imperfect social set of rules
Zurich Switzerland good morning hi this
is class from Zurich Switzerland I would
ask mr. Pincus
what would Washington do if the People's
Republic in China the communist regime
would do the same to the ambassador to
the United States as you did to the
Nicaraguans and this in pay ping where
you have held people which fled of the
tournament Claire
a actions to your ambassador Thank You
suruc for the call this morning touched
on him yeah we can't really say well
what the United States would do with its
the double standard argument again and
it's interesting though that we have
Fung media in the American Embassy in
Beijing and and we maintain the right to
protect that man however - it's not in
my opinion comparable particularly
comparable except in a very abstract
legal framework to say that Manuel
Noriega is a political refugee
comparable to somebody like Fung Misha
who was a leader of a pro-democracy
movement his country Buffalo New York
good morning good morning good morning
mr. gingy's the morning I would wanted
to be specific I hope you will be I want
to talk about the break-in at the
residence of the ambassador de nicaragua
from Nicaragua could you tell me first
of all what is your military service
been what is my what know what Terry
Farrell I serve in the military I've in
the military
second and last question how were you in
the room to see the military from the
United States rough up the officers no I
wasn't in Panama at all during that
period it's something that we've touched
on earlier also in writing your book how
many people did you talk to how long
have you worked on the book I actually
counted the interviews as I finished up
it was about a hundred and thirty
interviews of panamanians and and US
officials I began the book in 1986
before it it became a story of crisis
proportions because I was interested in
the murder of August botifarra the whom
I touched on earlier is the man who
really began the campaign to reveal
Manuel Noriega as drug dealings he was a
a populist himself a charismatic leader
who fought against the Somoza regime in
Nicaragua and then became disillusioned
and fought against the Sandinistas then
he fought against Noriega a kind of
quixotic romantic revolutionary and when
he came in to return to Panama in 1985
he was apprehended and executed and
actually beheaded and I became
interested in that because I arrived in
Panama on a trip to talk about
investigative reporting on the very day
that his body was found and I received a
lot of questions as I was giving my
lectures and I saw a certain parallel
between that in my previous book in
which a dissident Orlando Letelier was
killed by the Chilean secret police
actually here in Washington and I saw it
as a story of tracking down the crimes
of a of a military in power and that's
how I began that investigation of course
it's transmogrified many times and it's
become a much bigger story Blue Island
Illinois good morning good morning and
thank you a doesn't the two questions
that I hope do all to address them both
doesn't he find it ironic both that
President Jimmy trusted Torrio's a guy
only a little better than and this guy
and doesn't he also find it ironic that
the guy from Zurich doesn't appear to
know that before Najib before Najib's
predecessor in Afghanistan was ousted by
Najib's predecessor hey he had our
ambassador shot by his police in an
apparent rescue attempt from a
kidnapping
and while Gorbachev's the man of the
decade with a puppet state of
Afghanistan still being supplied to
greater levels and before their pullout
Bush is is castigated by the world for
rescuing Panama only the American people
in the Panamanians seem to appreciate
our rescue of them and everyone
including this guy seems to prefer to
characterize us as invaders instead of
like when we liberated Europe liberate
thank you
I one of the things about the Panama
story is the ironies there are so many
and they're so rich and for until the
invasion I found them in many cases very
humorous Noriega is a very colorful
character he's somebody who has toyed
with the United States he has thumbed
his nose at the most powerful leader in
the Western world and seemed to be
getting away with it
I think it's replete with ironies until
we of course turned this into an
invasion and and probably around 600
people now have died and I think as an
outcome of irony it becomes saddening
rather than an ironic we're seeing a
page this is page 8 from today's
Washington Post critics of invasion
still hard to find complaints come later
as a Panamanian is watching gi's
reception I'm going to drop this now to
to read but the gist of this article is
that everywhere US troops go the people
are welcoming them with with open arms
when you were working on your book what
did you find the Panamanians felt about
Americans and the government is it
different how they feel about the
government how they feel about Americans
and does this surprise you that they're
being the troops are being welcomed well
I I've been talking every day to people
in Panama and and it's a it's been
increasingly clear that the invasion is
accepted by the Panamanian people there
are very few people who the whatever is
left of the Opposition whatever is left
of the pro-military people have vanished
into the woodwork
perhaps in six months or three months
they'll come out there will be an
organized nationalistic movement that
will be based on opposition to the Pro
to to the pro US government and I think
that will emerge because Panama is one
of the most nationalistic countries in
in all of Central America it's the
country because of the overwhelming US
presence
however I think we shouldn't take away
from the Panamanians the the great
feeling of relief that this crisis is
finally over the country was literally
being strangled totally cut off from
from international not totally but it
but greatly cut off from international
commerce its banking center was almost
incapable of functioning and and this is
a country with whose economy as a
service economy they shipping registries
that the banks export import the canal
free zone all of these things depend on
my ability as a businessman to say well
when you do business in Panama it works
you can the rules work that maybe a
little pay off here or there that's the
cost of doing business perhaps but you
can you can depend on the system working
all of that was dismantled over the last
two years because of the sanctions the
unemployment doubled tripled 25 30 % of
the population was unemployed I think
more than the brutality of the
Panamanian Defense Forces which was also
increasing over the past over the past
year the people saw that the country was
going down a deep hole with no way out
and even despite the violence I think
they say finally it's over and I think
they greatly expect the United States to
help that there will be an import the
influx of of US aid the houses will be
rebuilt the United States will show
itself as a generous Victor just a few
seconds left for a quick last call from
Whitefield Colorado good morning
oh yeah yeah hello yes I visited and
I've noticed that Noriega has appointed
a lot of black put in Oh a s and today
and and and and and two to sixty United
Nations and I was wondering what was his
ethnical black background is he black
white or maker what yeah that's thanks
cholera that's an important observation
if you will notice the new government is
almost uniformly white the old
government was about 50/50 mixed
Panamanian whites blacks and an
mixed-race Noriega himself is is black
Indian and Spanish background and most
of the people in his government were of
that background panama is a country with
at least I think I mentioned this before
at least fifty percent of the people are
are of African background of some
portion or another and probably eighty
percent of the people are of some mixed
Indian Spanish and black ancestry so
this the racial factor is very important
the whole Caribbean coast area around
cologne on the and the Atlantic side the
northern side of the canal is is
predominantly black people that have
come from the Caribbean they were the
people that built the canal they were
brought in as laborers to build the
canal very well-educated people from the
Caribbean and I think we're going to
hear a lot from them because they were
dissatisfied with Noriega but they I
think are going to be very dissatisfied
with the new government as well and will
be demanding that there be some black
presence in the new government which
there isn't the book is our man in
Panama it's due out what date in March
third our guest this morning John dingus
foreign editor of National Public Radio
thanks for being with us thank you and
do it in and again we thank you for your
calls in your comments have a good day